andrew we're ready to give you uh the
game of the tournament uh how do you
feel about such a game
um
i mean when he played this rook fd1 it
just looked totally wrong because
he's moving a rook away from a king's
side lawyer i has very little to know
defenders so i thought like i didn't
calculate everything all the way
obviously but i assumed knight g4 i mean
something has to be working there for
black did you check this line before the
game or did he surprise you with this
taking on d5 and queen c2 which is quite
popular nowadays oh he surprised me with
this on 92 bishop d2 idea um
i wasn't exactly sure what to do but i
just try to play natural like 97 c5
looks pretty good for black and um and
what i got in the game was pretty
comfortable because uh this with the
isolated pawn the knight on each is
totally misplaced and he obviously has a
lot of weaknesses around his king the
knight coming in g4 sometimes absolutely
and he played this move knight to g4
right now he played this move bishop to
e1 you spent a lot of time at this point
trying to make queen to h4 work
did you see everything from afar
how did you come to the conclusion that
you have to go for queen to h4 and did
you see
all the ramifications after that knight
to f3 knight xc3 and so on yeah i mean
when i played knight g4 like i i had
already seen this quit h49393 idea very
quickly but it's not so clear which
makes it very hard and by the way black
has other options like not h2 and or
like after qh4 h3 for instance you can
start from 93 and then knight f3 that
was
the moment that we thought that you
might get a bit confused yeah but yeah
yeah we have to yeah i tried to be very
precise my calculations but i think the
knight of 393 is the best and others i
didn't see anything clear so here
that gf393
um queen a4 shack i mean 24 queen g5
track knight g3 um again it's very
tempting to play bishop d7 here it's a
very forcing line
but it seems like white holds on for
instance queen takes d7
um knight takes d1
and there's this move king g2
i think this was his idea and white is
holding on for instance rook takes e1
um rook d1
uh bishop f2
uh with that queen e3 queen gma but
there's queen g4 here and that's it
looks like y just holding on so
i just assumed that bishop takes h3 okay
first of all um i didn't see a clear
defense for him but like i just i
thought like even if he had something
here i married i have two pawns and his
like king side cover has been completely
blown open so it must be good for black
no matter what also might as well get
another mechanism of queen f6 queen
takes f3 around the king right
checkmating mechanism yeah this bishop
d2 defense i saw but queen f6 looked
pretty good for black so you know and i
think you were actually very very
precise with these last few moves so was
he after bishop right to e1 he was
making the best defensive moves uh but
you just kept on piling on the pressure
and it was just too late after bishop e1
queen to h4 was just a crushing victory
for you congratulations andrew and right
now i'm sure you're keeping an eye on
that game between christopher you and
david brosky what do you think of the
game um i actually haven't taken a look
so
not too sure what's going on well we're
trying to get some new commentators yes
let's take a look
we're recruiting
let's take a look at that game uh right
now and maybe you can give us your
assessment the one between christopher
you and david brotzky there it is
is he in time
or is he not
um
i would say it's probably a draw i think
probably a draw interesting um yeah
yeah because usually
um usually with the the side pawn like
the h pawn or a pawn is winning um if
you cut the king on the b file but but
here you need like the king to you need
the black's king's help to like force
luxon with the white bishop but here the
kings tied down can we force suicide oh
wait i'm not sure it
seems to me like it looks like a pretty
simple draw for white so actually let's
keep the rook on
right b8 or b7
and then maybe get the pawn to a4
so how do you how what what do you play
first things
right rook to b7 yeah king c2
so you want to stay on c3 and c2 i just
don't see what black is doing here
if you do go a4
then king's v3 can you see three and now
after rook to b3 you go king to c2 not
king to c4 no now
and what if i go with a rook to g3
well yes this is yeah this is win yes we
know that
um so after king to c2 what if i go rook
to g3 and try to come with the king no
oh wow
i actually didn't think of this
but how do you make progress
i just was just waiting too it's always
a good question
because this bishop is taking the b4
squares so uh i can put you in a suits
one though so i go king c4
and now i give you a check and if you go
to a3 i go king b5 that's it so you have
to go on the first round but now it's
with king b3
maybe it's a win
let's check the
table base
right before you live
it's a it's a win okay i'm wrong um
it's it's a win we did not uh no we we
know we knew before
we knew before that it's a win but it
did feel like white is making some
progress nevertheless he still uh seems
to be losing now
if he loses that's going to take you
half a point behind him with two rounds
to go how do you feel about your chances
i mean a half point lead with like two
two rounds ago is a pretty sizable
advantage to himself not expecting too
much and he's been playing very well
this tournament
i've had some very shaky moments um i
had a very avoidable loss against
christopher played terribly against abi
and uh against charissa i almost didn't
win so
i've had my shaky moments this
tournament so honestly i'm not expecting
too much but i mean it's always nice to
get back on track with two wins
absolutely congratulations andrew and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you very
much andrew just two two quick comments
uh you were wrong about the analysis but
nonetheless we still want to trade you
for alejandro you're in you're in you
you you you passed do you pass next
next next
really i cannot let this moment go
without saying you played a brilliant
game today and absolutely brilliant game
and keep that kind of form up you may be
on the podium
good luck in the championship rounds
yeah thanks so much
absolutely wow what a great surprise
i don't know but i'll
have to think about it